Mr. Yaba, what's the matter?
Are you all right?
Oh, you're here too, Michiru?
Have you gotten used to this town?
Yes. Kind of.
My, you seem unsure.
Chief Inspector, Yaba is escaping!
That's Yaba?
He's totally different than before!
He sure is.
You have permission to fire! Fire!
Damn! How did he become so brutal?
I'll stop him!
-What's that?
-There's a fire!
Yes, it's taken effect, just as expected.
We can't let him do any more damage!
He must be stopped!
He's smashed through the fence!
He'll get into the city!
What?
Shirou!
I'm good. I can handle this.
But your arm!
It's all better?
How can it resist even Ogami?
If that thing gets into the city,
there will be big trouble!
-What are you doing?
-I'll take care of it!
I'll carry him
to where there aren't any people!
-Don't be stupid! Get away!
-No!
Quit thinking you can do everything alone!
When the chips are down,
I can do what needs to be done!
Then show me what you can do!
Flap your wings harder!
Harder!
Give me even larger wings!
She's lifting that?
Quit struggling!
You bastard!
-The pier! There's nobody out there!
-Got it!
-He's struggling again!
-Drop him!
-From this high up?
-I don't care! Just do it!
-I'll be fine!
-Okay!